[Music]
hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
on october 11th 2010 english actor and
comedian stephen fry stood on a stage in
london he would talk fondly of a new
phone operating system by microsoft
called windows phone even though he was
a long time iphone enthusiast stephen
fry would relay his moments of delight
that the refreshingly new windows phone
provided him and he had good reason to
be so enthusiastic windows phone was
radically different and in many ways
ahead of its time it was much more
polished than android but was better
designed than apple's ios
windows phone could have still been here
today but some unfortunate blunders
destroyed the project
the remnants of nokia also built the
kitchen sink on windows phone and pretty
much sunk with it when all the dust had
settled only a 7 billion failure
remained so what went wrong
you are watching cold fusion tv
when steve jobs announced the iphone in
2007 the world had changed forever
without the public knowing it yet
smartphones were now actually intuitive
gone was the cumbersome navigation with
a keyboard taking up half the device at
all times
an all-encompassing multi-touch display
could transform the device to do any
task he wanted
though at the time not everyone was
convinced some thought that this new
touchscreen phone was just a novelty
that would fizzle out in a couple of
years
chief among them was microsoft ceo steve
bulmer
steve let me ask you about the iphone
and the zune if if i may
zoon uh was getting some traction and
steve jobs goes to mac world and he
pulls out this iphone what was your
first reaction when you saw that
500
fully subsidized with a plan i said that
is the most expensive phone in the world
and it doesn't appeal to business
customers because it doesn't have a
keyboard which makes it not a very good
email machine
how do you compete with that though he
sucked out a lot of the spotlight uh in
the last few weeks how do you compete
with that right now we're selling
millions and millions and millions of
phones a year
apple is selling zero phones a year
so how could steve bulmer be so
confident that the iphone wouldn't
succeed it may have to do with the fact
that microsoft had had a lot of
experience in mobile computing as far
back as 1996.
in that year bill gates would unveil the
handheld pc it was running windows ce
which was basically windows 3 tuned down
to run on simple hardware
through the years microsoft would revise
the mobile version of windows
by the time the iphone was released in
2007 microsoft were the second biggest
player in the mobile software space
aside from nokia symbian they saw no
threat from apple until they saw the
sales numbers of the iphone
in late 2008 microsoft realized their
mistake and got to work building their
own multi-touch device google had also
done the same
in 2010 the windows phone software was
revealed to take on the iphone
this is a navigation
animation that we call turn style so
it's a
animation into the panorama that the
concept appears to give the user context
that they could go left and right
to the panorama and as they pan through
you'll see that things kind of move in a
different uh there's a little bit of
parallax as we slide through uh the
panorama
calendar this is actually one of the
simpler
animations in the system but it's also
one of my favorites it's just something
really kind of i don't know beautiful
and powerful about the thought of just
being able to tapping on on a day within
your month view
and then just zooming directly in into
that day view and then back out again
taking styling cues from 50 year old
swiss design it would be typography
simplicity and motion that was at the
forefront of the design
right from the get-go from its outset in
2010 windows phone was the boldest and
most original reimagining of what a
smartphone could be three years after
apple's iphone introduction
unlike android windows phone was not a
recreation of the standard ios icon grid
and also unlike android windows phone
was slick it was fast and fluid on all
hardware
also remember that back then iphone
icons were still skeuomorphic and
samsung at the time were just copying
apple
android was pretty drab if you didn't
know how to customize ironically that's
how this channel got its start at the
very beginning i even made an app to
change the android interface ideal
booted windows phone 7 and android from
an htc phone so for a couple of years i
got to know both operating systems quite
well
the very first thing that one would
notice from windows phone back then is
just how responsive it was everything
was a fluid motion enhanced by tasteful
animation
there was also some depth to the ui
the dynamic tiles were efficient yet
practical you could make them as simple
or as complicated as you wanted
the on-screen keyboard was a delight to
use it was the very best of any
smartphone os and there was some thought
behind everything all the important
stuff was near the bottom of the screen
and this made it easy for one-handed use
overall it felt like software that was
five years ahead of its time this was a
solid foundation for microsoft
[Music]
the platform had a strong launch with a
star-studded list of partners from htc
to samsung and dell every large brand in
2010 was there but there was one brand
in particular that looked like the
perfect partner for microsoft
in a serendipitous moment in 2010 former
microsoft executive stephen elop became
nokia ceo microsoft saw an opportunity
and in an effort to save both mobile
brands they joined forces and nokia
would stake its entire future in windows
phone
the next year in 2011 the microsoft
nokia partnership would result in the
lumia series these phones would have
striking designs with a heavy focus on
camera functionality
would you mind moving your enormous
phone
you mean the enormously awesome galaxy
search one trick pony
aren't you a little young to have an
iphone
you want to go
i sheep copy bots autocorrect this
you think if they knew about the nokia
lumia they'd stop fighting all the time
i don't know i think they kind of like
fighting
the windows phone nokia lumia 920
engadget's reader's choice smartphone of
the year
[Music]
windows phone was looking strong the
phones were a refreshing addition to the
market and they ran beautifully
but there was a problem staring at a
beautiful phone all day gets pretty
boring pretty quickly if there's no apps
for it
from the perspective of app developers
windows phone was too late app
developers were already entrenched in
ios or android so nobody wanted to make
apps for a new system with a smaller
user base
and it was pretty rough for windows
phone consumers
for example instagram and youtube took
three years before arriving on the
platform
and this was a major problem what user
in their right mind would buy a phone
with basically no apps
it was looking grim but for a moment
there was at least hope you see
microsoft was about to launch project
astoria it was supposed to make android
app ports a piece of cake but
unfortunately it would ultimately fail
as microsoft and google never really saw
eye to eye and after this point things
only went downhill from here
when the windows phones didn't sell well
hardware manufacturers lost faith in the
ecosystem making phones for android was
much safer
with all of microsoft's partners turning
their back on windows phone microsoft
decided to double down their nokia
involvement
microsoft was putting ever-increasing
investment into the partnership and the
other brands increasingly felt like they
were being abandoned and this sentiment
would only grow
[Music]
nokia's mobile division was bought for
7.2 billion dollars
microsoft basically rebranded nokia
hardware with embossed microsoft logos
to strengthen the brand image
but still the lack of windows phone apps
had already driven a lot of would-be
customers away
but even within the corporate
relationship there were fundamental
conflicts that couldn't be resolved
microsoft wanted to take on the iphone
directly and this would involve a
tightly controlled lockdown system on
the other hand nokia wanted to go after
developing markets in india and other
areas of asia
in the end it left both sides frustrated
and unable to even gain enough focus and
stability to tackle the competition
to make matters worse microsoft changed
ceos from steve bulmer to their current
ceo satya nadella in 2014.
nadella saw windows phone as a loss and
decided to shift the company's
priorities away from it
by 2015 microsoft only had a 2.5 market
share
the consumers had spoken and they had
chosen apple and android
later in the year 8 000 employees were
fired from nokia
it was looking like the writing was on
the wall as time went on company
resources bound for the windows phone
project dwindled and later releases
became increasingly unstable even
microsoft continuum a software feature
that turned your phone into a windows pc
couldn't save the project
in 2017 it was curtains microsoft
stopped development of windows phone
it was all over in one of the most
beautiful failures
still getting that oled display you're
still getting great battery life you're
still getting powerful enough
performance because the great thing
about windows phone is it didn't require
a lot it was it was really well
optimized both with battery life and
power the best on screen keyboard there
is right here for messaging when i was
just typing out a couple emails on this
earlier and just doing some simple
google searches it was a pleasure and it
is it pains me
going back to other on-screen keyboards
when i know something like this existed
in the past and just has not been
carried forward but that's what makes it
that much more depressing going back and
using windows phone because you love the
live tiles you love the keyboard the
oled panel way ahead of their time and
the usability of it and the fact that
you're just like why couldn't this have
survived why didn't anybody pick up on
some of these things and run with them
in 2022 because these are still valuable
features that we'd enjoy having in a
phone today
if microsoft had been earlier to the
game successfully engaged developers
gave equal attention and incentives to
other manufacturers and allowed for a
less lockdown system perhaps windows
phone would have survived but hindsight
is 20 20. i do think it would have been
cool to see windows phone become
successful they did a lot of things
right really early and it would have
been very interesting to see what it
evolved into today
but ultimately consumers didn't see the
value in the whole windows phone package
if you like this episode and you want to
see another microsoft failure check out
the cold fusion episode on the microsoft
kin i'll leave a link to that below
feel free to have a browse of this
channel for any other content that may
interest you anyways thanks for watching
my name is digogo and you've been
watching cold fusion and i'll catch you
again soon for the next episode
cheers
[Music]
cold fusion
it's new thinking